[Music]
mr mcgowan so
mr paul mcgowan so if you'd like to
come forward over to the table that's
indicated the airport
um just to let you know that we are on
audio live stream today so there could
well be a wider audience than than as
indicated so
all right so um if you wouldn't mind
just switching on your microphone and
take us through your um
your submission points and um
and colleagues may well have questions
there so thank you thank you for your
time and for coming today
thank you for letting me uh attend um
might just short and sweet
uh it's pretty it's pretty
straightforward i think kelly's pretty
aware of everything
um
the plan there sort of uh outlines
that's the northeast development area i
haven't put the boundaries in i've just
highlighted where main power stadium is
the golf club
the north south collector road with the
shared cycle and pathway the east west
road
and the roundabout and also an
indication where the
proposed eastern bypass is going to
eventuate out um via mcphail ave
okay so um
the proposed uh
changes to the level of development
contributions so this just in the in the
blurb there
uh so it's fully supported by belgrove
obviously bell
i'm a director and project manager of
belgrove um rangura
um where this is the
the uh we own 65 hectares uh in in this
north block of the northeast development
area um this is
this um plan shows a an indicative lot
layout that we're working on at the
moment um
these the roading and uh pathway
infrastructure items in this proposal
are not only critical to the to the
development area but serve a wider
purpose
in terms of connectivity
both in terms of vehicular and
pedestrian and cycle traffic
in the rangoor and district network
number one
the north-south collector road which is
sort of highlighted in green
which goes through from
kippenberger right through the cold
stream exiting up
to the east of the main power stadium
this is a key
what i like to call an arterial
collector road
it'll collect the vehicle traffic as
well as cycle pedestrian traffic from
both within the northeast development
area as well as significant traffic from
cold stream and the sports stadium we
imagine there's going to be a fairly
high volume of traffic coming through
from the stadium events and uh so forth
um further it also forms the northern
end
of the proposed uh eastern bypass which
originates from line side road one day
in the future
we expect significant traffic volumes
from that bypass once it's constructed
number two
the roundabout highlighted in in the
pink there which is at the intersection
of kippenberger
uh macphail and the in the new north
south collector road
uh this is a key component of the of the
roading network it will enable
safe and sensible traffic control for
firstly the
the north-south arterial collector road
right through from cold stream
it will provide
control for
the east-west
kippenburger road connection from bring
euro through the wood end
and thirdly
uh traffic that will be coming up from
the south or going south from the new
eastern bypass when it eventuates
uh
third item
um
now the north south uh just going back
to number one the north south collector
road does have a shed cycle
and
pedestrian pathway in it as well
number three
uh highlighted it's the east the shared
cycle and pathway uh in the east west
road highlighted in blue
this enables a fully connected cyclone
pathway in the development area to be
used not only by residents but also
people from rangiora and the wider the
wider district
sort of
gets the whole connectivity thing for
the cycle
and pedestrian network
now the funding which is in the proposal
which
for four different funding
portions is the odp
roading development contributions the
district riding developer contributions
district-wide rates
and
something out of the existing roading
subdivision budget
we've discussed this with council staff
e.g kelly
and we're pretty much
in agreement with that
so just in conclusion
the proposal supports making transport
options accessible convenient reliable
sustainable it will provide the
necessary infrastructure linkages and
optimal outcomes to keep pace with the
increasing traffic volumes of vehicles
cycles and pedestrians within
the development area rangiora and the
wider district
we think the funding proposals reflect a
fair cost allocation
in relation to the wider use of these
infrastructure components to benefit
ring europe
or to benefit the ranger and why the
district residents in waimak and and
beyond
short and sweet
i think thanks paul it's uh very clear
uh submission points um questions from
colleagues
thank you just just if you just use your
mic sorry thank you thank you thank you
um paul that's um very exciting
and uh um
well presented so thank you for that um
do we have um um a timeline on when um
when you might get it be able to get
underway with um all the compliances and
right you'll see on the plan there
you'll see the um
you'll see the first stage um down the
the bottom there uh just from captain
burger north and you'll see that the two
two the two flow past done on those sort
of arrows right
yeah
it's it's
yeah so stage one of the development is
the is the first block
up from kittenburg
we we um
obviously we we're caught up um
in between the existing district plan
and the pdp
so what we have done is we have a
made a fast track application
under the covered regulations
we are which is a
two-stage process through to mfe we're
just awaiting the tick off
from
off the minister's desk um i have talked
to this about um dan to dan about this
so we're hoping that that's going to be
ticked off and through to the panel
because the panel or the commission
there actually issues the issues the
resource consents necessary and they are
all the consents which normally ecan and
the council would do
so we are ready to go we our timeline is
basically stage one kicking off in
january or february next year
and obviously we'll work our way up
we're working on stage two three and
four which will enable the
the rest of the north-south collector
road so um we think that we're going to
probably have to actually do another
fast track application because i don't
think the proposed district plan is
going to keep up with
you know the timeline between
notification and operative status is
probably gonna
you know 18 months to 24 months means
that we're going to want to kick off the
next stages and we just don't think the
district plan will have caught up
it tends to be taking a longer
longer than we thought to get
get the new plan
so yeah we're ready to go we're just
waiting for
zoning tick-offs and so forth
now thank you any further questions
yes i'm sort of not for i'm not up to
speed with where we went with it but i
guess
well as much as
i probably don't want to get into the
specifics that just uh perhaps the point
that
paul made around
engagement with mfv and the minister
following a conversation uh around that
that i have
set up a time sorry we're in the process
of setting up a time
to uh have that conversation
because apparently it requires my uh
further involvement uh
uh through a discussion around the
minister so uh
we'll do so you've made contact yes we
have yeah we're in the process of
getting a time so we can have that um
conversation around it okay you know
obviously central nothing seems to move
that fast in central government and
obviously covert and so forth have uh
push push time frames out yeah so it's
using the special fast track provision
yes and so as a requirement of that
apparently the minister
would like to speak to me and my role so
uh
and we got that feedback last week so
we're just setting it up at the moment
just for clarity
we're very keen to get this going as
fast as possible you know as you
possibly know and if you want to buy a
section and ring your at the moment um
you you can't you can't buy one in kai
poi the only available sections are in
ravenswood and ravenswood is um
what we consider not an optimal
subdivision you've got very limited
section sizes
in our development we've got section
sizes ranging from 250 square meters
right up to a thousand you know
multi-high density medium density as
well as you know the
standard residential sizes and being a
rural township there is quite a demand
for those larger sections of you know
seven eight nine hundred square meters
so we're hoping to provide everything
we've got a commercial shopping center
going in in the stage one i'm not quite
sure when that'll happen obviously
that's a
chicken and egg thing about needing the
sort of critical mass of residents
we've yeah it's quite an interesting
we've got the uh the
the belgrave homestead is in there which
is being retained um and we've got the
top end of the cam river um so yes it's
a it's a nice and exciting
development and um yeah we're keen to
get it going this
there's sure a lot of expectation
growing the town about it so you're
right
yeah we we we haven't done any
advertising we um
have got a bit of a splash page on our
west park range or a website from that
subdivision that we did uh completed a
couple years ago i have about 150
registrations of interest from private
buyers
not and that doesn't include the sort of
25 plus bill companies that we're
dealing with
so
the 190 or 200 sections in this first
stage is certainly not going to satisfy
the demand um and that that's as i said
we're working on stages three four now
yeah
that's all it's pleasing to see a
developer of your experience leading
this uh in doing this because um not any
experience but you do high quality
development so yeah thank you it's
pleased to see yeah we still got a name
associated there so yeah we're gonna
this we're gonna model this a bit on
west park you know so the oaks and west
park you know that sort of quality i
tend to find ravens was a little bit
not quite what we want to be but we're
obviously trying to
keep sections or have sections that are
affordable as well
it is a challenge
and
paul councillor williams
thank you good
proposal here
to click the road um from kiplingburg
ramp to coltrane road um i noticed you
the first um
that's where you've got the arrows the
um south of it will you be doing that
whole collector road
right in the go or just half of it well
well i think what we'll do is we'll do
it up to up to the top of stage one and
then we'll do um do the next bit um
[Music]
we've obviously got some infrastructure
issues with
water and surge waste water so i think
we'll do it up to the top of stage one
and then as soon as we get going we'll
kick our kick on and i think the last
little bit kelly will be lindsey bain
sorting that out so what why that
question was um
i'd actually like to see that whole row
done first so we can take a lot of the
big trucks and um
um contract vehicles and that um coming
from the busy
red so it would come down from the other
side of the um
the coltrane road area to keep
um
kippenberger avenue a little bit cleared
with trucks and um tradies and all that
type of thing so yeah i just thought on
that i'm just not quite sure if we'll be
allowed to do that with the zoning thing
i'm just
not
well that's a matter outside of our
confines today but that's perhaps a
question yeah it's something we can look
at we we have it would it would be ideal
yeah it would be ideal um there may be
some engineering issues we're just yeah
or even the shed from golf links road
through the where the blue strip is in
terms of here
kelly and team can reflect on and come
back yeah
they need some further discussion here
yeah okay
any further questions i think we're
really clear uh with the proposal and
what your view is on on that which is
i'm really good thank you for
supplying the uh documents to go with
that and we appreciate your time
excellent thank you for your time okay
thank you
thank you cheers
right
all right uh can we close the door here
we're still on live stream at the moment
it continues in live stream okay doesn't
it
that's the we read button okay
and this site
sorry
the trick
it gets us all
um we might just adjourn for a few
minutes get a cup of tea and
and then come back and uh we'll do the
um
go through the the deliberation aspect
so
sorry is there hot water over there okay
what
[Music]
just wait till we're back on
we're back live
all right so we come to item five which
is the
hearing panel deliberations we've got a
uh the memo here in the report and
lindley and
kelly would you like to highlight
anything in those reports
sorry
there weren't a lot of submitters to the
consultation um six of the seven were in
support of our proposal
um
one of the submitters was concerned
about any future development of rangiora
which was outside our brief and
there were no responses received against
the proposal
the council has two options available
which you'll see in the deliberation
notes on the
final page and
it's a matter of whether we support the
proposal as it stands
or whether the proposal is not supported
and
we
go back to the drawing board
thank you
so that's on page um eight
of our um papers here
the hearing agenda which has got the two
options there option one and two
um from this this panel has the
delegation to make that decision or is
it report back to council just remind me
please
yes the the hearing panel can make
um
can identify their preferred option and
their report
going back to council which we'll write
on your behalf will
identify their preferred option and the
recommendation to council will be to
adopt the preferred option okay so
uh
kelly do you want anything
um no i suppose
you know as far as the impact of the
proposal um with
paul mcgowan in belle grove is the
majority land tone land holder within
the
affected area for the development
contributions will be loving so i think
it is quite um
you know i i it's good that they they
support
this proposal as well as um
they
you know have the greatest impact on the
proposal
and to just be clear um all land owners
around
had the opportunity were written to and
had the opportunity to make a submission
if they wished that's right so we
directly mailed all of the property
owners within the
odp area
to make them aware of the the
consultation we also had
a
session
to answer any questions that was
advertised to all of the property owners
within the
area and we did not have anybody turn up
at that information session
okay
any other questions
so just just been clear so that i sorry
i should have checked this before i came
so just from lindy's point
does this hearing panel
we report back to council is that
correct
yeah so we need we would need to sorry
if you could use a we would need to um
incorporate that in the recommendations
that uh
what our decision is but it's a decision
that goes back to reports back to
council so would we be yeah okay
and i will write the report on your
behalf at the end of the deliberations
there'll be a report which i will um
work with you on and that will go
through to council for their adoption of
the um of the proposal and the change to
the development contribution schedule
okay
so um
i think we should just
perhaps just
before we come back to the
recommendation because there's two there
is perhaps just be clear on the
uh the questions and the responses that
are there i've
personally read through those and
um
and understand where they're coming from
how the any questions on the
points that have been raised of clarity
so as has been mentioned all are in
favor really apart from from one
so and the one that was
uh opposed really was on the basis that
they just weren't in supportive
development in general which is really
um well
and that's a relevant point but it's not
really relevant to our decision
necessarily here
okay all right
so then we have
i guess we're clear on what the
development contributions that are
listed are which is on page
we've had the um submission from
belgrave
uh today by mr mcgowan who's
which largely it affects the property
that he's on and
they as a developer are supportive of
that proposal
so um
i guess really it comes to the options
there there's options one or two on page
eight and i just wanted just to check
with
both um council warden williams on your
thoughts on that record those
recommendations
you're going to move the first option
i would second the first option i think
it's uh um
so just come to you the minute that's
what it is yes i'd like to move um
option one yes
and that's seconded by council award yes
um and
would you like to speak
yeah i think it's a um
it's inevitable this um type of
development's got to go i head for
renewal it's a prime
piece of land and i think
everybody in the hall of waimakariri has
been expecting this to be happening for
years to
years ago so um
it's a perfect development the actual
groundwork and everything there is
actually pretty good um
ground for a subdivision
and um yeah i fully support it really
good
um
i think it's um a very well thought out
and very
um
considered
um sharing of of air of course and well
done to
kelly and the staff who've worked
alongside the developer for
for bringing forward something that's
very reasonable and will give us a very
good result so what i can say is well
done to you and
also
well done to
the developer for
belgrove for
coming to a really good agreement which
i think is is is well balanced
uh i
endorse the comments of colleagues there
um
i think it makes absolute sense that we
set these development contributions
we've been out and consulted on those
that it affects
as mentioned before with uh
belgrave coming here today they're in
support of those so
which is good it's it's important that
um we do set these so we can start to
recover
uh these costs so that as a as being
mentioned as a partnership in terms of
the costs that we go forward this area
being developed i agree with councillor
williams
there is a real expectation
from our community that this has got on
with and also from the development
community uh because we're at a point
where we've run out of sections
presently so this and seeing this
development happen i think is really
important
um and mr mcgowan mentioned the fast
track processes which he's
involved with um presently
um
but i think it's well being thought
through through the
option one and i'm in support of that
option and
obviously we'll work through to make
sure the hearing report reflects
the
comments that are in here and the
submissions that have come forward so
thank you
um
do you wish to write a reply
just one other thing i just
didn't mention i think it's really good
because it's going to connect our new
sports stadium together with the rest of
the town and given extra linkages there
and
the cycle way going from one end to the
other
built into it it's going to give access
for
uh
children to cycle to closer to the
sports stadium and the safety of that is
going to be a plus as well so um
it's it's that linkage is is very good
and going to connect um anger
better than what it is now so it's
really good
good points council williams and that
i'll put the
um option that's the option one all
those in favor please say hi
country
declare that carried
all right so
on that basis uh we've um considered the
memo the statement the proposal we're
clear on
and we
have considered the bangla table report
now comes to the deliberation notes
which uh
um
will be developed in conjunction
with us
as the panel
and then we'll
i guess release our decision to the
council
so really there's no other business to
discuss right at the moment
so i am happy to declare that the
hearing is closed uh well do we close
the hearing at this point or june
close it's just a double check but
they're the practice i
haven't done a resource consent work
consent hearing for a wee while so
to close the hearing at this point
um
and clear the hearing closed thank you
everyone for your attendance and
um our staff support
and
the work they've done making sure that
we can meet in these conditions as well
with the live uh
[Music]
you